تم القبض على ما لا يقل عن ثمانية أشخاص
بتهمة اغتصاب فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
في ولاية ماهاراشترا الهندية. وقالت
الضحية في بيان
للجنة رعاية الطفل إنها تعرضت للاغتصاب من قبل
400 شخص تحدثوا إلى سي إن إن مسؤولًا
من اللجنة قال إن عامل المنجم
كانت تتسول في محطة للحافلات
وأجبرها ثلاثة رجال على العمل بالجنس
بزعم اغتصابها ،
وسجلت الشرطة قضية بموجب قانون
خاص لحماية الأطفال من
الجرائم الجنسية وتحت أقسام الاغتصاب والتحرش
في قانون العقوبات الهندي.  تم أيضًا تسجيل الحالة
بموجب قانون حظر زواج الأطفال
، كانت
متزوجة من رجل يبلغ من العمر 33 عامًا في
سن 13 وزعمت أنه اعتدى عليها جنسياً ،
وقد قام البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا أيضًا
بتسمية اثنين من أفراد الشرطة في
بيان للطفل  لجنة الرعاية الاجتماعية
للاعتداء الجنسي ،
رفضت الشرطة المحلية التعليق على هذا الادعاء
عندما اتصلت بها CNN على الرغم من
الإصلاحات القانونية التي أدخلت بعد
الاغتصاب الجماعي المروع في الهند  في عام 2012 ،
تشير البيانات الحكومية إلى حدوث اغتصاب
كل 17 دقيقة تقريبًا في الهند ، كما
أن عدد القضايا المتراكمة
مرتفع بشكل مذهل في الهند وفقًا
للحكومة الهندية ، حيث كان هناك أكثر من
240 ألف قضية معلقة في المحاكم
تتعلق بالاغتصاب والجرائم الجنسية ضد
القصر حتى ديسمبر 2019. vedica cnn
new delhi